what we'll be talking about some mucho
free next-gen update stuff with me I
have amazing guests I have my part in
crime Alicia cozera hi guys
I have another acting narrative director
sorry Philip baber hello and Charles
trembling our engineering director hello
it's nice to be able to talk about The
Witcher finals finally I mean we've been
you know quite busy with preparing the
update you know with making sure
everything is on point so it's time that
we can actually show you guys the
gameplay we can talk about those things
in details and you know to be proud even
more than we are right now right okay
um so yeah we have a lot of cool things
to talk about uh today but I think I
want to start with mentioning that the
update is free if you get the game so
you know prepare your PCS your consoles
uh very comfortable chairs and sofas get
yourself some drinks for you know the
witcher-free sessions
blankets book some time off of work
and do it on the 14th of December yes
the release is December 14th yes and
yeah okay let's dive in to cool things
okay so the first thing I think we
should mention is the ray tracing yeah
that's the next gen feature yes so uh uh
for the PC we have the ray Trace Global
elimination so uh that looks the visual
Fidelity is amazing it replaced the old
PVR that we had we also have the uh MPN
occlusion the ray tracing inclusion
again
you're good but we have other stuff we
have of course we integrated the FSR 2
and we have a dlss we have also Dynamic
resolution scaling and we have also a
very nice new SSR screen space
reflection because before it was only
for the water yeah but now it's for
everything
so I hope that it will oh shiny armor I
can I can feel that
uh okay so Ray tracing the game will
look even better right now with you know
all those options but I think we also
have one more for PC enthusiasts like me
yeah so we also like try to push even
further so we have also a new ultra plus
uh settings that you can play with uh
that include like for example the
background characters grasting City
level of details all the settings we had
uh it's not a preset but you can Tinker
around play and see if it's uh you know
if it works it's good for your machine
and then you know have fun
I'm pretty sure everyone in here and you
know on the other side of the screen
definitely I mean provided you have good
enough PC we're all gonna try yeah
our best right
um okay so you know the game looks
amazing we have super cool you know
retracing options we have the ultra plus
settings and all that combined in photo
yes so now you can showcase the beauty
of The Witcher 3 in the photo mode and
we know that you already were taking
amazing screenshots from The Witcher 3
but we wanted to give you a little help
so we implemented a photo mode into the
game you have some options to you know
stop girl stop the scene and play a
little bit with the settings maybe give
it a little bit of different mood change
the angle something like that so yeah I
think I think you're gonna be able to
create some really amazing shots and
really can't wait to see what you do
because we know from cyberpunk that
you guys are like breathtaking with that
and with the Witcher I think you can
also create something amazing so can't
wait for December 14th seriously
internet's gonna be flooded with
screenshots Twitter which are everywhere
literally and I think I think we have to
maybe do that you know a photo mode
contest oh yeah another occasion for
sure we do a lot of our photo mode
contest so keep your eyes open for for
something on The Witcher okay so photo
mode awesome stuff but we also have
really cool cameras added in this part
like I have my favorite one I'm not
gonna spell it yet but I think we
already so so the spoiler in the
gameplay we did a little bit but yeah so
actually it wasn't a planned feature
initially it was more of an experiment
uh so you know how would the game look
like if we had the camera a little bit
closer a little bit to the side uh and
it honestly worked so well like you know
we showed it to many of our veteran
gameplay designers to play around with
it that we decided to make it a full
feature so you can choose to have a new
alternative camera mode that is much
closer to geralt we of course know that
you know people want to have their
control so you know it works when you're
exploring exploring it works in combat
or when you're riding on roach but for
all of these states you can actually
also choose to have the old camera
so you can combine when I'm exploring I
want to be really close to geralt but
when I'm on roach I actually want to be
far away so essentially you can mix and
match when I personally play the game
now I choose the alternative new camera
all the time you know I played The
Witcher wealth and many times so for me
it's actually new to play it like this
because it makes it feel like it's a bit
of a different game yeah I remember the
first time we were walking novigrad we
did we're like this is great like oh
yeah we want that yeah you know the
angles how you can walk through the
crowd it it feels a bit different I like
it yeah for me my favorite is like the
horse camera that you know you can see
the friendship between geralt and
roaches like the you know dynamic door
so like that's gonna be my choice for
sure but yeah the camera looks pretty
pretty cool and I think a lot of people
actually
I actually like it and enjoy playing it
um okay so we covered PC parts right now
maybe let's jump to the next gen okay
yes okay so you know it's not the next
next-gen update if we don't have two
modes so performance and quality mode
for uh for consoles and 60 and 30 FPS
for Series S uh did we add something
specific to those mods maybe uh yeah for
the well for the Siri X and PS5 uh the
quality mode we do have also the global
illumination retrace the ambient Fusion
of course and of course the SSR will be
there for the console we also have the
fsr2 integrated as we did for cyberpunk
uh so this is ready to go and of course
Dynamic resolution scaling to be sure
that we get the smooth ride 60 FPS and
30fps well and additionally if you play
on your PlayStation 5 or the Xbox series
X NS a lot of those other improvements
we made so you know the general quality
settings higher textures level of detail
all of that of course is also much
higher than it used to be on the old
chain consoles so this will also be
looking nicer no matter if you have
quality or performance yeah I think it's
much closer to the
Ultra that then you know before on
Console was real or so
I look great I mean true
but also there's something specific for
PS5 players you know this really nice
controller that they have so we added
haptic feedback and
do we have anything specific connected
to Adaptive triggers made
well I mean you know I think the thing
you notice the most is of course in
combat so you know when you do your
signs when the sword hits the enemy or
hits another sword you can actually now
feel uh the impact because you know it's
done with the sound waves of the actual
sound so you do have a bit of more of a
visceral feeling when you actually use
this controller so I personally like
that one a lot it's a nice it's a nice
addition that makes the combat feel a
bit nicer
one thing I noticed on a gameplay that
we are showing on the screen is that the
quick cast that's another feature that I
wanna to talk about with you guys yeah
so again similar as the camera items was
an experimental feature so as you can
tell lots of the veteran developers or
new developers working on this project
they just also wanted to do those cool
things and it's one of those elements
that a personal shout out to Edo varendi
one of our designers he actually worked
on this personally as his Hobby and then
essentially asked can I try to make a
proper version of this in the game and
it essentially means that when you were
using signs in the vanilla game you
always went to the radio menu where the
time slowed down you choose your sign
and then you cast it and now both on
controller and on keyboard essentially
you do not ever have to go to that
radial menu again if you activate that
mode so instead of the you know pressing
let's say in the controller R2 to cast
you now hold it and then all the face
buttons or L2 become your signs so a is
Art L2 is igne so essentially you can
just jump around doing your different
signs however you want without having to
pause the game so it's a bit more of an
advanced feature because now you have to
use two buttons instead of one
essentially so it is of course as with
the camera it's a choice that you can
activate and of course there's also a
tutorial for how to use it but
personally as someone who plays the game
a lot especially if you have a sign belt
I would never want to go back again oh
yeah definitely
so we are making uh Stein builds
um pretty much a default kind of not a
default but
I would say more direct less I would say
maybe also it's not annoying to always
have to go back to the menu so now I can
just feel smoothly I'm in combat and I
never have to go out of it so I would
say it's more fun that way I can I can
definitely see myself messing up with
all the buttons combo wrong sign
it's gonna work I'm pretty sure you know
I'll get my head around it so worry not
we'll see how that works okay we have
the quick signs we have all the you know
additional gameplay features and and you
know that we will be talking about but
this is something I want to I want to
mention because we've seen that also on
the gameplay it's the it's the default
map like I've seen a lot of cool filters
right there so maybe something for
Philip defense it's personal so so it's
actually a new filter uh so you know I
can speak for my personal experience I
was one of the people who added all
those Smuggler caches and skellige and
uh you know the way this content is
meant is oh you find it while exploring
the world and it's nice I found some
cool thing I can go on uh but it's not
meant necessarily as a checklist or you
should do all of those 50 things and the
way the map presented it with you know
all the question marks I think for some
players made it feel like they have to
do all of those things and of course the
map looked very filled with lots of
icons so we added this new filter that
essentially hides those question marks
from your map and also hides the boat
icons from your map which means the map
is much cleaner now and you can play the
game you know essentially finding those
things naturally not feeling forced to
do all of them but of course you know we
also know that there are players who
like this there are players who want to
get all the content who want to make
sure that they found everything there is
to find so this is only a map filter
default you can also switch over to the
filter all and then you have all of
those icons there so you know it's not
that we're getting rid of it it's very
much that if you prefer to find these
things organically I think this mode is
for you I really love how with all of
the features that we we're talking about
we give a player a choice so so yes yeah
this is amazing they can actually if if
you liked what was already there feel
free to keep it if you want to try
something new try it yeah and that's
actually that's very much the idea
behind this whole dextgen Edition which
is if you really love The Witcher and
you know the game this shouldn't now
feel like a different game this should
be the game that you lost
experiences exactly and you know even
with the ray tracing it looks like the
game in your dreams that you know that
you remember how it looked like and when
you compare it the difference is really
staggering but you know the art style
didn't suddenly change and it's still
true to what it should be and it's the
same for the features you can play the
game you want to play but you can also
experiment with some new features
exactly so I can still go to skeleton
and just look for a look on map and see
like where is the map okay
um okay you guys mentioned that you know
games from the dream and you know it
looks amazing I keep saying that because
I'm amazed how good it looks so you know
I know we added some extra adjustments
right to environment to like you know
characters and whatnot can we maybe
mention some of them yeah we have a lot
actually uh I think we have a new all
the grass has been improved almost all
the folio asset has been he worked we
also have a lot of environment
mesh changed also higher resolution
better textures almost for everything
and I think that we also integrated
quite a lot of mods
and also on Console this time around not
just on PC so shout out also I think for
the HD reward that we integrated
and also all the monsters everything has
to be have been improved we also
increase the budgets for the streaming
so of course that means that the the
texture will be of course higher
resolution everywhere and yeah there
were many these little projects where
you know old Witcher veterans that had
plans to do something they now had a
chance to you know oh I'll quickly
install the engine for you know two
weeks and I'll make some tweaks so you
know even small things that you know by
themselves don't feel like a lot but
when all of them come together it's
really nice so you know now you see
smoke come up from Villages far in the
distance the cobblestones in Novi grad
are not normal Maps anymore they're
actually yeah you know 3D so you know
all of these things just kind of stuff
missing the village yeah
but this is awesome we also
some grass ticket I don't know wow what
a beautiful grass and new clouds wow
they actually you know if you look at
them side by side the difference is
amazing even with like this one small
change yeah but and this is again the
weather the clouds the sky it's supposed
to look like you remember but a lot of
those assets were upgraded or you know
just similar with the camera added a bit
more variety so as an example you might
have new weather conditions that weren't
there before
I mean like it all sounds like you guys
were super busy and I know you were like
even busier than than that and but I
guess everyone was so happy to jump back
to The Witcher right to yeah to actually
give that extra push for one of the best
games I've ever played in my life yeah I
think the whole team was actually quite
happy when we discussed about okay guys
we need to jump to The Witcher yep let's
let's do it let's go back no worries
yeah and you know shout out to a
production team for letting us do a lot
of these things because some of those
fixes were also done kind of illegally
by people you know people assigned to
work on cyberpunk you know maybe like
sneak in one hour oh I'm gonna help you
with that cool thing so you know usually
people were very happy to just quickly
jump in and do this cool thing
this is amazing coming back to our like
Legacy coming back home yes yeah
um okay so we we covered some of the
gameplay features obviously there will
be more
um minor tweaks some fixes and whatnot
uh we'll definitely get back to it later
but you know we we also hear our
community right oh yeah yeah guys like
forums Reddit Twitter Facebook Instagram
we read all of that and it's not only
about us as a community team I'm sure
you guys are in the dev also go there
and check out what what our community is
requesting what they're talking about so
we read that and we actually put some of
those stuff uh to life so for example in
this update we are giving you some
additional modes for girl to walk so on
the controller so if you push the stick
very lightly he's gonna walk slowly and
if you tap it he's gonna Sprint so the
the boss will get out I like it like
he'll he'll be like I'm the the king now
here yeah yeah and there's also there's
it's actually also an option again where
were in the vanilla game you press your
a button on the controller to Sprint but
also actually lots of other games people
prefer that you know on the stick and
this is also something that we don't
change by default but if you want it you
can activate it for yourself
that's that's cool yeah so other
requests also also something that you
probably already saw in the gameplay
that we were showing you you can now
scale subtitles so if you don't see that
well or if you if you want to have an
easier experience with the game you can
now make them bigger make them smaller
whichever you like it's just something
that I think is going to be useful for
all of us yeah I think
in my times of you know 2015 being tech
support representative we've got a lot
of requests for scale supplies so I'm
pretty sure people will will be happy
but this is one of the requests but the
other other thing I'm pretty sure we
want to cover that oh yeah yeah is the
two Quest fixes two specific questions
yeah you guys probably probably know
this Quest because you know comments
about that pop-up even even now like
please fix that and we are we are fixing
that we are fixing from Office sure and
uh and the Wolf are more hand so yeah we
tried to do the the tricky way of also
if you played the game previously and it
actually is broken on your safe when you
install the patch it should actually now
also work retroactively and actually
those are the two famous ones yes yeah
but there are actually quite a bunch
more yeah that we actually also fixed so
you know there's a search Smith who
sometimes didn't like to talk to you
that one should work now and you know
lots of just small issues like we
actually did another QA pass of the game
stutters in cutscenes small stuff that
we just try to add more polish
you mentioned something yeah behind the
scenes yeah it's a nice quality of life
Improvement so you know our code team
actually did a fix because you know it
actually isn't that easy to pull it off
there's a reason why it was like that in
the vanilla game that now during scenes
and cutscenes you can pause the game
some people might not even remember that
that wasn't possible yeah but directly
yeah so you know if if you have someone
at the door or you need to go to the
toilet while a scene is playing you can
pause it now it's it's nice quality of
life Improvement so we won't have like
uh mom no I can't pause it
well if you use it as an excuse you can
still do it okay
um okay so skate subtitles fixes to like
to most famous
um but we also adding uh a new subtitles
yes I mean it's not only subtitles it's
the entire voice over for the game so
actual dubbing uh we are adding Chinese
uh simplified so now the game will be
fully voiced in Chinese and this is a
lot of players that that can enjoy enjoy
the game in their native language so I
hope you guys like it but besides that
there are also some improvements to
other languages so hopefully the the
experience will be better in those as
well can it even get any better oh I
mean I mean we we have some some more
stuff I think like some minimap that's
something I heard that there were some
cool feature about minimum yeah so you
know it's again a smaller feature so you
know I don't want to oversell all of
these things but it's nice quality of
life stuff so in the main game you could
have have your mini map your quest
objectives always showing or you could
turn those off but then they were off
exactly until you turn them on in the
main menu but essentially we try to make
a hybrid mode of this so when you're
just exploring walking around those
things will be invisible but of course
you can if you want to check the minimap
to know you're going in the right
direction you can just press your focus
mode button and then it will show for
you know a long like seven seconds or so
so you have time to orient yourself
until it nicely disappears again but if
you keep wanting to just have it there
for a long time you can just hold a
button so you know also or if you're in
combat the mini map and your objective
they do then also just dynamically show
up so you know you have all of your
information so we just try to give you
more Choice with this hopefully I won't
get lost hopefully but you can still
keep you can you still have the choice
you can still keep the minimum yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna try to hire to
actually get the full exploration mode
you know uh in my next gameplay
um but yeah I'm pretty sure yeah same I
mean it's Forest Rivers it's all
beautiful so I'm not gonna I think night
city is easier because like the streets
and here I just get lost in the forest
but you know it's even if you get lost
right you're surrounded by all this
beauty you know you just look and you
know you can hear the trees you can hear
the wind uh you can even you know hear
those small kids singing something in
there
for example but it just you're not
feeling even mad for being lost so you
know that's that's super really really
cool
um okay so you know we we've been
talking for uh for a while now uh we
mentioned some major stuff that are
coming to to the patch but we also
adding some minor tweaks improvements
here and there so it won't be just what
we're talking here right and you know as
a reminder update will be free and it's
also an upgrade right from PlayStation 4
to PlayStation Farm five four from Xbox
uh to series X and NS right so you know
it's it's gonna be a lot
yeah I mean we're gonna have patch notes
um before hopefully December 14th so you
can you can check out all the changes
but I'm pretty sure that we won't be
able to fit all of them
yeah yes I mean we like surprises oh you
probably know that so so we keep some
stuff hidden for for you to discover
while you're playing the game exactly
the patch note varies little
improvements and surprises that's I
think that's the best attention I think
one surprise that we can just slightly
show maybe it's the one that's something
that we that we announced already during
The Witcher console the Netflix DLC
Quest
um we will be showing uh or we are
actually showing right now the very very
beginning of the quest but we are not
gonna dive in yes it's very important we
don't want to spoil anything because the
thing is you know I also don't want to
over sell it we just thought that if
we're offering those new uh you know
armors swords items that we just want to
make it feel a bit more part of the game
and of course if it's a cool armor you
know as with other armors in the game
there should be some Quest or content
connected to it so we try to you know
make a quest that makes it part of the
Game's new field chose a very cool place
for that for that yes yeah so if you're
a big Witcher fan you know that place
it's very famous for people wondering
what is going on there what is going on
exactly and now something surprise is
there yeah and you know again it was a
it was more of an improvised thing where
so many Witcher veterans which is like
hey can you help us with this can you
help us with this and in the end it came
together really nicely yeah but I think
I think it was not so improvised
afterwards because we even brought our
voice actors back to to record some
lines for the for the quest right yeah
so we we almost forced the hand of our
localization but you know oh maybe you
know we'll just have 50 lines or maybe
uh you know so it worked worked out
really well and it was really nice to
just hear all the geralts again to be
honest as you know that cockle or you
know all the other actors it's it's cool
amazing okay so I finished the quest and
I get no I don't get the armor I get the
uh yeah yeah you have to put it
somewhere yes
but I think apart from you know get out
season one and season two armor and and
swords uh we also have two extra things
from from the Netflix so we have uh
yaskir dandelion whichever name we are
using here uh we have an alternative
outfit for him and you can actually just
switch it on from the get going
yeah yeah
uh and one fun thing that we added uh is
Anil guard armor uh if you if you turn
it on and go to the annual guard card
you can you can see you can see what we
actually yeah what it looks like
um okay so I think we covered most of
the things that we wanted to talk about
today
we left only one thing
yeah yeah this is the feature if you if
you play cyberpunk You Know It uh the
cross saves this progression cross
progression so if you log into your DOD
account on your PC PS5 Xbox
etc etc you can easily just move uh your
safes from one platform to another so
you started on PC a while back now you
bought PS5 you want to play play the
same the same playthrough no problem
your safes will sink and you can easily
start from where you where you finished
last time
uh okay I think that's that's it that's
not it obviously there was gonna be much
more in the update in the patch notes
we'll be talking about the update for
the next couple of weeks yeah definitely
yeah
um but this is it for today
um so yeah you know remember guys the
update is free if you already own the
game
um you know just be ready December 14th
coming fast coming fast exactly
um and I think before we leave we have
one tiny maybe not a tiny but thing for
you to to watch
um after we're uh we're off and yeah we
all invite you to play The Witcher once
again with whatever settings you want
tell us what you think about this update
we cannot wait to see the screenshots
all the you know all your feedback
um maybe there will be you know
something that you wanna also have
included maybe we'll do some extra mod
magic again uh who knows but yeah guys
see you offline and online because we
have one very small thing prepared for
you closer to the release We're Not
Gonna spoil it but it's gonna be super
cool and yeah see you December 14th see
you guys bye guys
Nerf guards crossed the pontar in the
East Mains war is coming
War Changes Everything by order of the
hierarchy whosoever conceals a mage in
their home shall burn alongside him or
her
[Music]
nilfgaard on One Bank redania on the
other drooling over the city like dogs
over a juicy bone
[Applause]
we are at War and she's in danger
you will find her and bring her to me
she's a child of the Elder blood so now
I've gotta find Siri and if you find her
the girl will die
[Music]
burn in the Eternal fire why are you
helping her because she's a danger a
mortal one a power that can destroy the
world
must find her geralt
before the wild Hunt does
[Applause]
[Music]
we'll find her or someone who knows what
happened to her
who are you
you know who I am
[Applause]
the legend cannot be killed can it
the wild Hunt will be here soon the
coming for series
[Applause]
all right